looks like LA's radical district
attorney George gasone has really
outdone himself when it comes to
promoting dangerous leftwing ideal
ideology over the safety of his City
This Time by tapping a cop hating former
public defender as his new Chief of
Staff say Hello to Tiffany blacknell she
once called the LAPD barbarians and an
occupying Army she said that prison was
Obsolete and needed to be abolished
black now also loves to wear t-shirts
that say the police are trained to kill
us and here's the kicker she once
boasted about being a looter herself
during the rodne king riots in La saying
quote I was a looter in 1992 when the
opportunity arose we took some bleep so
don't come on my page complaining about
protesters or looters so Greg isn't this
just another step in Das like George
gasone tearing down the current system
to replace it with their own yeah it's
kind of weird it's like as community
ities unite in Collective outrage over
crime they simply hire more radicals
that enhance Division and I think there
is an underlying fear that if blacks and
whites and Browns wise up and band
together to throw throw out these
radicals they need to stress division
even more and that only makes the cities
worse it's a vicious cycle so they make
it about race they make it about
identity to keep the citizens divided
and therefore powerless but this again
is a what wear problem
I don't care about her beliefs at all
she looted in ' 91 she hates cops she
prefers criminals over victims get it
she can host MSNBC for all I care it's
the where she's being installed in a
department that should be focused on
public safety and protecting citizens
not criminals and again you cannot and
we talk about this you can't fix a
problem if all the so-called fixers are
from the same ideological bucket but I
think what's happening is we see what we
see as a problem they see as the
intended result the result is to flip
Society so that cultural reparations
Trump Law and Order so we keep
complaining but this is exactly what
they want so Jessica the mayor of La uh
is has said that she wants to hire more
police officers because of this crime
problem but why would you want to become
a police officer when you have these
kinds of people in charge who say that
you're an oppressor that you want to
kill people rather than keeping the
community
I don't know which is why we're seeing
shortages in almost every major city and
you hear the press conferences from the
chiefs of police who most of the time
are Democrats as well talking about how
there's a tremendous disconnect going on
and that they can't you know rally the
troops to go out there and to do this
job and people are taking early
retirement and and it's a huge problem
but there also is it kind of connects
back to what we were talking about in
the last block a big disc connect with
how people are feeling and the actual
stats on the ground so the FBI today
released their data for the third
quarter of 2023 so they compare it to
this time last year and no one would
deny of course that there was a surge
During the covid period but violent
crime is down 8% property crime is down
6.3% it's at its lowest level since 1961
and I've been talking about the drop in
the murder rates not in Washington DC
that is an outlier but in all these
other major cities like New York where
we are in Chicago in Los Angeles
and it's not getting any traction in
that story and I understand that crime
is a what you feel problem and it's
definitely a what you read problems
Gallup has 77% of Americans and this is
across Democrats Republicans and
independents think that crime is going
up but you look at that FBI data and you
think how how is this disconnect the
chasm this large well Dana isn't that a
lot like saying well inflation is going
down it's the same it's the same issue
right so right you could look at
statistics and say well the the stock
market's up like there's more job
openings than ever like why are do these
people feel so bad well you'll take one
particular thing what do people have to
buy every single day for survival food
and food is up and they will not forget
that and also especially there are
consequences for some of the crime that
hurts everything else for example
Washington DC losing the two major
sports teams to go to Virginia what did
that mean that means that in that area
that which is was just redeveloped with
a lot of money and was a great place to
go now what happens so they leave means
nobody else is going to come no one's
going to rent the hotel rooms no one's
going to go to the restaurants the small
businesses everything you so you start
to see that quality of life go down um
and that is a big issue with this one
and with gaso and one of the things that
this woman had done before in her career
it was reported that in 2020 she went
behind the backs of of the prosecutor
and the victim's family and worked with
the defendant in order to get him a
sweetheart deal a plea deal so that
worked so as a public defender it wasn't
to defend the public it was was to
defend the defendant and make things
easier for them so gasone I think is a
victim of this idea that if I surround
my myself with people who agree with me
then I'm going to get better that's not
necessarily true and actually in our
next block you're going to listen to a a
great leader who has a very different
management and Leadership philosophy and
that's why he's been successful yeah
Jesse picking up on on Jana's point
about the criminals that they don't want
to be in prison child sex offenders cop
killers people who kill and attack
nurses while they're waiting for the bus
to go help other people in the hospital
these are the kinds of people that they
are defending and and keeping out of
prison so they can reoffend and hurt
more innoc they need sixth and seventh
chances Katie don't you understand they
are victims of a white supremacist
criminal justice system and they will
not heal until we empty all of the
prisons and defund all of the police
there's only three options why he hired
this woman one he's in love with her two
he didn't vet her three he vetted her
and thought I'm going to hire a cating
looter now when we do hiring around here
I look deep I go into the Instagram I go
into the Facebook I go into the Myspace
if I have to and I look at what's
written on t-shirts I look if what kind
of alcohol is sitting next to them I
look everywhere and if I see one thing
that not makes me suspicious red flag we
don't go to their house remember that
time you broke into that house do you
remember and then we move stuff around
and make it look like we weren't in
there yeah and you know you're you're
cherry-picking again Jessica if you look
at the NYPD statistics for here in
Manhattan from 2019 to
2023 every single element of crime is up
every single one no if you compare it to
19 was just in the New York Post would
you going to call your other colleague a
liar again now you also have to trust
your gut when I go out now I take my
wedding band off I put it in my pocket
because I don't want to get jacked and
I'm very athletic think that they're
going to that's that's what you tell
your wife when you forget to put it back
on stop it now of all the things I said
on the show that's going to get me in
trouble you leave your watch on oh shut
up Dana W can I just say the job of a
public defender is to defend their
client they shouldn't have that job if
it's change the topic then or change the
title yeah crime is not down that's like
saying inflation is down when
it's as expensive as it was no they
won't talk to me I wonder why you don't
want to talk to them Jesse call your
lawyer for sure all right up next one
trillion humans could live in outer
space billionaire Jeff basos making some
out of the world predictions hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else